I'm here to address
the allegations
of inappropriate
behavior on my part.
It's amazing that in 2014, there
can still be a witch hunt.
I'd like to thank everyone
who has stood by me,
especially my
beautiful husband, Trentman.
Yes, you have a question?
Can you explain the graphic
photos of yourself
that you tweeted?
I tweeted those photos
privately to my doctor,
who was available only
via direct message.
I see, so your doctor's
Twitter handle is
"Hung as (bleep)"?
Correct.
Dr. Hung.
He is Korean, and yes, my
vagina's in perfect health.
Thank you for your concern.
What about the lewd texts
sent from your cell phone
to college-aged interns?
I--
What do you consider lewd?
"Your (bleep),
my mouth right now."
Okay, that was an
autocorrect issue.
Now, I'd like to focus
on the work I've done
since I've been
in office.
Have there been some scandals?
Yes.
Have I done a good job?
No.
Well, that's why I need
another term.
Why did you send the guy
an invite
to your pussy on Facebook?
That was a misunderstanding.
I'm new to Facebook.
You put "invite"
and then "pussy."
I mean, how confusing
is that?
Would you comment, please,
on allegations
that you were seen coming out
of Slayer's dressing room
with your face
and hair covered
in what appeared to be
tapioca pudding?
Um... no.
We were going through
your old yearbook,
and can you clarify
your senior quote,
"Where you see a fist,
I see a comfortable chair"?
I at this time would like
to take the last question.
Is anything related to not
what you just asked?
Yes?
Yes, what about allegations
you had sexual relations
with Chris Christie's
dog walker
while on government property?
That wasn't a dog,
that was a prostitute,
and it was at my gym.
(all shouting)
Okay, well, looks like you
caught your witch, all right?
This is just a case of
slut-shaming.
This slut is not ashamed.
Especially of the perfect puss
pic I tweeted?
You're welcome!
You are welcome!
There are more where that
came from, okay?
If you're lucky, you'll catch
another glimpse.
At this time, if anybody has
any further questions,
you can address them to my
campaign manager... Damone.
Isn't that right, Damone?
That's it for questions
for the congresswoman.
Her husband will make
a brief statement
while I talk to the
congresswoman in private.
I just want to say that I love
my wife and I'm standing by her.
Our private life is just
that, private,
and I don't think
that she should be punished
just because of the perfect
pussy picture
that you guys published.
Thank you.